The first answer can't be true because the units of measurement are wrong.
This would be tons divided by tons which would leave us with a measurement unit of 1
and years per ton won't work either--we had to have tons per year,
the rate of change of a number of tons, so this doesn't work.
This expression would not more the growth but the decay of fish minus the constant
times the number of fish and this would be something like immigration not harvesting.
Some constant is being edit to the rate of change.
We have an immigration of 4 times 10âµ tons per year, so these two can't be the answer,
and we are left with the third one--0.5 per year times the number of fish.
The positive growth rate as is appropriate for exponential growth
and then there is a loss with a minus sign, which models harvesting.